hey youtubers it's Charlie hopefully you
guys have all had a chance to see the
arrow season 3 premiere there's a whole
lot of stuff to get through so I'm gonna
start with my top 10 moments then I'll
do my review and then I'll try and
circle back around in case I miss
anything I'll also be doing a combined
arrow flash Q&A and I'll try to get some
more bonus videos up pretty soon so
careful for spoilers from the episode if
you haven't seen it yet I'll wait just a
sec okay ready here we go top 10 moments
number 10 team arrow is kicking ass and
taking names
ever since the season 2 finale Oliver
and team arrow have been systematically
taking down organized crime they're
actually covering that in the arrow
season 2.5 comic so I'll try to include
that in future reviews the opening
action scene is just an example of how
they basically been steamrolling every
bad guy they can find and we get to see
Roy in action in his shiny new costume
number 9 Roy isn't full on sidekick mode
as Arsenal Stephen Amell joked at Comic
Con that he now has the second best suit
on the show and I actually believe a
matte ass this is what it looks like
when it's not super dark out it is kind
of funny that it looks so cool but you
really don't see the details because
they always film at night and for those
asking yes Roy is going to be the
Arsenal version of his character not red
arrow number 8 welcome to the Hong Kong
flashbacks this is gonna be like the new
LeeAnn you of season 3 Amanda Waller's
just trying to get Oliver to work for as
if he were like a Suicide Squad member
they haven't used that term specifically
to describe what they're doing but just
think of it as like a precursor to the
Suicide Squad his handlers that we met
are masayo
and satsu in the comics satsu the wife
becomes katana I've already done a big
video explaining her character that I'll
add a link to in the description she's
probably gonna be one of the flashback
characters that shows up in the future
and if you didn't recognize the actress
it's Rila Fukushima
she played Yukio in the Wolverine so
she's crossing the phantom streams from
the Marvel Universe to the DC Universe
number 7 Quentin unofficially joins team
arrow
he's Katz and Lance now and it looks
like he's been helping Oliver in the
field for a while now how about that you
failed this city line he hasn't said
that in a while obviously the episode
brought a lot of those extracurricular
activities into question but essentially
that speech at the end was him saying
I'm not gonna stop doing this even
though
lands me in the hospital I was kind of
glad that Laurel didn't push him on it
too much it just means that we're gonna
see more of Quentin doing nighttime
stuff with the arrow if you're wondering
why he's bald I think it's because of
the captain's hat I'm not sure if it was
a production thing or if it's a
character thing I think it's because
they thought he looked funny with the
hat on when he had hair so that's why
Quentin is bald this season number six
meet the new vertigo Peter Stormare it's
so funny how many villains he plays on
TV he's playing a villain right now on
the blacklist if you're confused he's
just taking up the mantle his name is
Werner zertal and that's actually a
comic book character but he's not really
gonna be the version in the comic books
he's gonna be arrows version it'll be a
little bit different I like that they
didn't acknowledge that the count had
died but that was what his whole speech
was about some things never die just
saying that the name vertigo would
continue to be passed on he's gonna be
one of the mid-level villains this
season just like brother blood was last
year the drug that he's pushing is just
the same vertigo I thought it was a
little silly to have Oliver take another
shot in the chest the second time they
fought I feel like he would have been
wearing thicker body armor after that
first encounter but I think it's just
because they wanted to show him
overcoming his fears number 5 Felicity
is working in a buy more so if you're
not sure what a buy more is that's just
a reference to Chuck the TV show Brandon
Roth played a character on it so they
were just having a bit of fun with that
you have to remember though that she and
Oliver aren't working at Queen
consolidated
Oliver's basically broke so Felicity has
to earn money so that's why she has this
job the interesting thing about Brandon
Roth on Chuck is is that he played a
villain on that show and here he's
definitely gonna be one of the heroes
since his character is buying a
controlling interest in Queen
consolidated they all might be working
together again real soon most of his
scenes Brandon Roth Cosette has been
with Felicity like the first six
episodes he said all his scenes have
just been with felicity number four Ray
Palmer has a plan to save the city you
can tell he's not a bad guy he just
wants to save the city like Oliver and
he's really upbeat and positive about it
there's nothing sinister about him he
does have some secrets that we'll learn
in a couple episodes though but his
character Ray Palmer is the atom from
the comic books he will become that
character through the course of this
season we're meeting him before that
though like he's still a normal person
he hasn't taken on a superhero persona
yet about a month ago
Brandon Roth said that he had seen
concept art for the atom super suit at
the time they'd only shot about six
episodes so I'm thinking we're gonna see
the atom suit in the mid-season finale
because that's a two-parter the arrow
half is called The Brave and the bold
that's the title of the episode which is
full-on Justice League like they're
doing Justice League on TV everybody
could just go right ahead and flip out
about how cool that is
the other big half of his speech about
rebranding Starling city as Star City
that's basically what it was called in
the comics like there is no Starling
city in the comics it's called Star City
I'm kind of wondering if the producers
planned things this way all along like
showing how Starling becomes Star City
and just to address the 400 pound
gorilla in the room yes
Ray Palmer will come between Oliver and
Felicity but I think when you guys see
their scenes you'll enjoy it it'll be
fun like Brandon Routh will be fun on
the show felicity is just gonna have a
few more options available to her she
has got like three superheroes banging
down the door to date her we even saw
her kissing Grant Gustin in a flash
promo
she is definitely getting some attention
this year number three Diggle and Lyla
have a baby I totally didn't expect this
to go down in the first episode they
will get some of their own Suicide Squad
episodes this year but as for the baby
I'm not really sure what the plan is to
incorporate it into this story it is a
huge deal I mean a Diggle baby is a big
deal but because filming with babies is
really difficult they might not show it
a lot on screen like we might not
actually see the baby a whole lot number
two Sarah is murdered the person that
shot her was Komodo we just didn't see
his face he's one of the other mid-level
villains this year for all intents and
purposes she is dead or at least they
want us to think that with that black
canary mask rolling off onto the ground
it's a giant call to action for Laurel
if you haven't seen the pictures
Kate Cassidy has actually been posting a
bunch of her workouts she is hardcore
like she's gonna give Stephen Amell a
run for his money in terms of fitness if
you remember the boxing scene earlier in
the episode one of the fighters was
junior Ramirez he's playing Wildcat on
the show like another comic book
character he'll be getting some scenes
with her pretty soon so it's possible he
could train her to fight I'm not
expecting Laurel
Black Canary anytime soon this season
but it does seem like they're definitely
implying that's gonna go down and my
number one moment all of the fanfiction
olicity made reality this was totally
crazy it was like everyone's tumblr
fanfiction was brought to life but they
do take it all back at the end of the
episode like they're not gonna keep on
dating felicity pretty much said they
were done as a couple it sucks but that
doesn't mean that they'll never end up
together but like I said this season she
will have ships with Oliver Grant Gustin
and Brandon Ralph
so Felicity is gonna be pretty busy
Oliver on the other hand seems like he's
gonna be spending a lot of time brooding
but as you probably noticed there are a
few big things we did not see in the
episode namely Rachel Ghul Komodo or at
least his face and team Merlyn the next
episode is called Sara so that's
directly gonna follow up on this final
scene but pretty much all these people
we will meet or see by the fourth
episode including Rachel Ghul let me
know that what was your favorite moment
and what do you think about Brandon
Roth's character so far overall I gave
the episode a solid b-plus it is
definitely my favorite arrow premiere so
far one of the things that's really
impressed me about the production just
in general has been their willingness to
go into the comic books especially with
the flash and all the crossover in real
life now likes it becomes this big metal
thing they're doing Justice League on
television that's amazing like they are
beating the movies to Justice League I
think my favorite performance was from
Stephen Amell
he smiled more in this episode than he
had in all of seasons 1 and 2 combined
for a little while we got to see a new
Oliver like a really light-hearted
version of the character obviously that
changed at the end and he's gonna be
going a little bit darker now just
because he feels like he has to be the
arrow and not Oliver Queen Stephen Amell
himself says some funny stuff about it
he said that when they were filming
Felicity scenes and Oliver had to smile
a lot the director had to ask him to
redo it a lot just because he couldn't
hit the right amount of smile like he
would always smile too much or not
enough like he was just not used to
smiling on camera as an actor like it
was just a really funny real-life meta
thing I just like the idea that you play
characters that are so serious that you
just don't know how to smile on camera
as a regular actor it's just hilarious
so I've already done a whole bunch of
bonus videos on a lot of these
characters I'll add links in the
description if you want to learn about
Kitana or you want to learn about the
atom character I will be doing more
bonus videos throughout the season and I
will be doing weekly Q&A s the next one
is actually gonna post tomorrow so be
sure to subscribe to get that I'm
probably gonna be doing some DC related
giveaways just because Gotham and all
these other shows are on right now is
literally like a week of DC programming
right now click here to learn all about
Brandon rouse Adam character and click
here for my review of the flash thank
you so much for watching so let's all
high-five everyone go rewatch the
episode